hi guys sci-fi recapped here
welcome back to the black mirror series
recap before we start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a drama science fiction series
from black mirror seasons 4 called hang
the dj this episode has an unpredictable
plot twist with bonus explanations from
us watch it till the end to find out
the movie starts with frank who is
talking to an artificial intelligence
system installed on a small circular
tablet called coach
the coach commands him to go towards the
hub a huge and mall-like building he
then enters the restaurant and meets amy
who is also following the coach's
instruction the pair discovered that it
is their first time meeting someone
through the system which automatically
chooses romantic relationships for its
users with fixed periods of time when
they tap their tablets at the same time
they find out that their encounter will
only last for 12 hours
after dinner amy and frank are taken to
a numbered house passing an encircling
huge wall on the way the couple seemed
confused and lost as frank asked the
coach whether they could have sex or not
while amy is also seeking for advice
from the tablet
they end up just having simple
conversations and sleeping next to each
other the next morning amy and frank
partways after their relationship
duration counts down to zero in their
separate conversation with the system it
is revealed that the system simulates
users into numerous relationships and
collects data on them in order to match
the users with their ultimate compatible
other on the user's pairing day it also
claims that it has a 99.8 success rate
to find a perfect match for the users
amy and frank then get assigned to their
new partners amy is assigned a nine
months relationship with lenny an
attractive old hand at the system while
frank is assigned a one-year
relationship with an emotionless and
humorless girl named nicola
since it is lenny's fifth time he
suggests that it is the best to have sex
straight away up front and amy agrees to
it on the other hand frank is having
difficulty to understand his new partner
as she demands a lot while they are
having sex
frank looks depressed
the next day while playing tennis alone
frank discovers that he is unable to
walk away from the current partner and
has to continue the relationship until
the duration ends
unexpectedly frank meets amy while
attending other people's pairing day
they are having a good time together and
amy also introduces lenny to frank
before they go it seems like amy and
frank are still having feelings for each
other
as time goes by we can see that their
relationship is not as romantic as their
first encounter anymore
when amy's relationship with lenny ends
amy is assigned to a string of short
relationships that becomes increasingly
meaningless for her
when frank's relationship with nicola
finally expires amy and frank are once
again matched and decide not to check
the relationship duration
as their relationship continues frank
becomes worried and distracted by the
fact that their relationship will reach
an end
one night he breaks his promise to amy
and decides to check their relationship
duration one-sidedly it initially says
five years but then keeps recalibrating
to the shorter duration until it settles
on only 20 hours the coach informs frank
that one-sided observation has
destabilized the expired date the next
day amy confronts frank about his weird
behavior and he admits that he broke the
promise and checked the expired date
telling amy that they only have an hour
left
they argue with frank suggesting that
they have to rebel and escape from the
system by climbing the huge wall but amy
is already too angry and leaves frank
alone
frank is devastated and begs the coach
to undo what he has done
the coach also states that failure to
comply with the system may result in
banishment
after another string of
indistinguishable short relationships
the coach finally informs amy that her
ultimate match has been found and her
pairing day will be tomorrow the coach
also tells her that the ultimate match
is someone she has never met before and
gives amy the last opportunity to say
farewell to one person of her choosing
amy immediately chooses frank then
throws her tablet to the pool amy meets
frank at the restaurant where they meet
for the first time and discover that the
farewell duration is just less than 90
seconds the pair state that they want
each other and want to go against the
system amy tells frank that they must be
undergoing a test and rebelling against
the system as the way to pass it they
agree to rebel by climbing the huge
encircling wall
as they start to leave the restaurant a
guard tries to stop them with a taser
but amy defies the guard and suddenly
everyone freezes
the two make it to the wall
while they are climbing the world around
them begins to disintegrate and they too
as well
the pair end up in a black room with a
number 998 above their heads surrounded
by dozens of dissolving identical frank
and amy doppelgangers
they look out and fade out of existence
as a digital counter announces that 998
rebellions have occurred out of 1000
simulations
at the end of the episode the scene goes
to the real world where the real life
version of amy and frank lock eyes with
each other and smile as the lyrics hang
the dj from the song panic plays in the
background and amy begins to approach
frank
hang the dj is basically the black
mirror version of tinder as it takes
place in a virtual reality in which
couples are paired by the system and are
told how long their relationship will
last amy and frank who are paired up in
the beginning of the episode can't stop
thinking about each other after they
part ways
even though the system tells them their
time is up they rebel and run away
hoping to see a system-free world behind
the huge wall
instead it is revealed that the entire
episode was taking place inside and
dating app which runs multiple
simulations to see how compatible frank
and amy are in the real world we see
that the app conducts 1000 simulations
but only two times the pair did not
rebel thus making them a 99.8 match on
this dating system brooker the writer of
the episode states that the system was
deliberately designed with amounts of
unfavorable condition
if they do rebel it means that they are
destined to be together and if they
don't rebel the system has served its
purpose and your reality ends
and now frank and amy are about to take
the first step on their relationship
journey together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching